*Grape Surgery Noises*
(i know all of you is dancing)
THEY DID SURGERY
ON A GRAPE
(wow)
have you heard about this?
AUGHHHHHHHH
this can't be true
there is no way
they did surgery on a grape
lemme look at my second most reliable news source...
SO IN TODAYS VIDIYO
tHeY dId a SUrgERy oN a gRaPe
the prophecy was true.
how could we have we been so blind?
*puts on epic glasses*
this happens 8 years ago, really?
oh I thought it happened recently *laughs*
oh is that the joke?
*the realization*
oh, before this video gets started too much,
mErCh.
what are you frickin' doin?
check out merch.
link in bIsCrIpTiOn
we got the brand new Pew-News,
merch, designed by me!
I love these hoodies,
They look very slick
look at that
MMM (very sexy Swede)
mmm
We also have the
~bich lasagna~ merch
out as well!
nothing personal
🅱️-Series
but I need to cash in on this
they are up today so check out
represent.com/PewDiePie
you don't wanna be the person
that hasn't bought merch before Chrismas
trust me.
it's gonna go bad for you.
in the most important matter,
they did surgery on a... grape.
they did surgery..
on
a grape
guys, they frickin' did it.
they did surgery on a grape.
They did SURGERY on a grape.
...they did surgery on a grape.
they did surgery on a grape?
that's literally impossible.
oh
my
fricking gosh
if Ben Shapiro is shocked,
then I think we all should be pretty...
sHocKed
Tom Hanks of course
is gonna play in that Marvel adaptation
as
Grape Surgery Man
can't wait for that one.
now that Stan Lee is.. *dead*
haters said THEY WILL NEVER..
THEY WILL NEVER do surgery on a grape.
but they did.
8 years ago
why is this a meme now?
stop.
stop this meme is so obnoxious
this is worst then the
"WeIrD fLeX bUt OkAy"
this is the new version
of weird flex but ok.
you do understand that right?
you can apply this information to literally
any context of a
any social interaction
"HEY HOW DO YOU DO?"
"THEY DID SURGERY ON A GRAPE!"
"I JUST ATE A GRAPE!"
"they did-
did you know?"
"they-
did you know that they did surgery
on a grape?"
"bet you didn't know that!"
"happened eight years ago"
you wanna WOW any of your-
friends, colleagues, loved ones-
grapes??
just hit 'em with the fact that
they did surgery on a grape.
but a lot of people don't understand that surgery does-
come with a risk involved;
not all grapes livez
*video plays*
*crowd cheers*
no one can ever say dipping fries in your Frosty
is weird again.
they did surgery on a grape.
excuse me Wendy-
i believe it's my job to kill the memes.
what are you doing?
pathetic.
I'm the one who does
👏 meme
👏 review
NO ONE ELSE
(upset Ben Shapiro in a bunny outfit)
they did surgery on a grape.
whoa. this is forced.
oh yeah 'cause all other memes are so natural
everyone just gets onboard-
completely not to just miss out on the joke
and not feel part of the group, it's all-
Hey guys have you-
ha-
have you guys seen this..?
have you guys seen this guy's neck?
(stares at us) (without moving) (pewds are you okay)
now this is a natural meme-
*laugh*
no just kidding.
*Clap clap*
the neck meme gets of course,
surgery on a grape.
what the *FLUFF*?
did I just rate the neck meme..?
what is wrong with my brain?
the grape meme gets of course (👏 x2),
they did surgery on a grape/10
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
that's the rating. ~enjoy it~
now this man's neck; can we talk about
we NEED to talk about this man's neck-
my god this neck's man is BIG
THIS 👏 MAN'S 👏 NECK is VERY 👏 LARGE
why is no one talking about this?
everyone is all about
"tHeY dId SuRgErY oN a GrApE"
I'm like...
"WeLl ThIs MaN's NeCk Is BIG"
that's how you reply with anyone going with
them: "they did surgery on a grape! :O"
you: "oh yeah?? have you seen this man's neck?"
them: "oh wow~ that is a very large neck"
you: "that's goddamn right it's a big neck!"
this man's name is Charles Dion McDowell.
he was arrested in-
guess it!
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Florida! HA Ha ha
who would've thought!
he was arrested in Florida
never would've guessed!
i swear to god some alien ship crashed in Florida
and mutated a bunch of people
and then the
that's a bit mean and harsh to say
i mean...
mutation doesn't have to be bad
i mean look at this man's neck
now
uhhh
the sheriff posted this on
Facebook
*laugh*
and the comments are uh..
beautiful!
boy *laugh*
boy look like he could drink peanut butter
*snicker*
if he hiccup, too hard
he'll swallow his whole head!
*pewds is losing it*
why are all the comments so neckative!!
*inhale*
wonder when his necks court date is
these jokes...
finally someone realises that's
that these jokes aren't funny
this is someone's brother
someone's uncle
dad, or
neckphew
*pewds losing his shit* (again)
dude gets sent to the guillotine and it breaks on his neck
this man single handedly destroyed the
French revolution
this man is the one punch man of necks
nothing can penetrate this man
nothing.
how got stopped by the police is beyond me
when you do chin-ups for a living
Charles Dion McDowell is captured. his neck is still at large.
god
damn
his neck is big
but
he's not just any neck
he's Jolly Saint Neck
he's the father figure of Christmas
Thank you Santa Jesus
neck
they did surgery on a grape/10
*clap* 👏*clap* 👏
that's what I'm rating this meme
Haa Haa Haa!
Waa Waa Waa!
who wants a muffin?! *Echos*
Ahhhh!
i'm a muffin!
and it's muffin time!
who wants a muffin!?
please, I-
have you guys heard this song?
it's straight up fire bro
why are all my favourite rappers doing covers of this muffin song
Waa Waa Waa!
Ahhh! i'm a muffin!
(+ Pewds singing along beautifully)
and it's muffin time
who wants a muffin?!
(+ Pewds singing along beautifully)
please, I just wanna die..
*depression attacks Pewds*
(he is also concerned)
*ear rape* AHHHHH! I'm a muffin!
and it's muffin time
who wants a muffin?
please I just wanna die,,,,,,
hey somebody kill me!
hey is it muffin time?
have you had a muffin today?
*oof*
*inhale*
muffin meme,
gets a
they did surgery on a graph/10
*laugh*
*Pewds sexy screaming*
"what, what did you say?"
"i didn't say anything"
oh
"i'm going to say the n-word"
*crowd cheers*
*Pewds laughs*
at least there's one meme still kicking it
*laughs*
it's a goddamn awful meme
but it's- it's still alive goddamn it
*clap* 👏*clap* 👏
no matter how many times, third time i've shown it!
it just doesn't die!
i don't know what to do!
i guess i have no power
over the-
(dont say it)
next meme
*clap* 👏*clap* 👏
meme review next meme or whatever it is
we actually have memes this week, how 'bout that
*Pewds stares at us* (again)
one meme revolving my name
that's right, it's
my very pleasure
to review this meme
to kill it, once and for all!
i'M sIcK oF iT
ThIs Is BuLlYiNg
tHiS iS cYbEr BuLlYiNg
If I hAd SuSaN's NuMbEr On SpEeD-dIaL
WhIcH i HaVe
I wOuLd CaLl HeR uP
aNd I wIlL sAy
delete everyone. (o_o)
YoU kNoW wHaT
eXeCuTe ArTiClE 13
because I'm sick of it
It'S nOt OkAy
*Pewds stares at us* (for a third time)
you think I'm use to bullying?
you think I'm used to being treated like a
like a laughing stock every single day
no one takes me seriously
i have thoughts, i have feelings
(sure you do)
no one cares about them
(you're right we don't)
so this is what I get
*ding*
*shitty music*
(wait a minute,,,)
someone took a picture
sn unsolicited image
in my own spare time
minding my own business
returning the shop from the shopping centre
and people just photoshop it
to make it look like...
the cart is taking me back
or
that- the legs swapped
really clever (x2)
oh because I don't have legs?
is that why?
dehumanising.
yOu'Re DeHuMaNiSiNg Me
i do have legs
it was a joke
i swear to god i have legs
(sure you do)
oh you're trying to rub it in
that i'm not part of Disney anymore
is that what this is?
lego version!
at least I can appreciate the aesthetic of this meme
thank you very much
(you're welcome pewds)
oh look at that,
the tables have been turned
what even is this!
*laughing*
okay see, this one makes sense
because if i don't have legs
this is how i'd go around
this is actually the un-photoshopped version
this is the original
of this meme
what even is this then?
it doesn't even make
any
fricken
sense
hey look!
no legs
how 'bout that
this is the un-edited version!
of this meme
we found it
finally
oh my god
goddamnit
*more shitty music*
*snickers*
*clap* 👏
but of course
like all good memes
they will find one day
a peer meme review
to see their last...
..moment
*press f in comments to pay respects*
to take their last breath
and- and this meme is no exception
*clap* 👏*clap* 👏
this meme gets a
*contemplating his life*
*short laugh*
*mumble*
sorry I was just thinking about
something else
*dead inside*
this meme of course gets a
10/ten
because it involves me
so
it's automatically 10/ten
*clap* 👏
check out the pew-news merch!
that's right
we ship before Christmas
if you order it now
so it's time,,
(link in BiScRiPtIoN)
it's time my fellow-
bros?
bro fist
*less shitty music*
at least this one
i can appreciate
*more less shitty music*